[Aplausos]
muchas gracias
hace pocos días fui acusado de ser
optimista
quizás porque pensaban que soy iluso
pero yo he podido comprobar en el tiempo
que el optimismo es una herramienta es
una herramienta que transforma problemas
en oportunidades según es una
herramienta que permite traspasar
barreras porque uno tiene la vista en el
futuro de hecho hay un psiquiatra muy
famoso contemporáneo de freud que vivió
la barbarie de la guerra de los campos
de concentración durante la segunda
guerra mundial viktor frankl que
escribió un libro que se llama el hombre
en búsqueda de sentido
y es una de las cosas que observo está
viviendo esa pesadilla dentro de los
campos de concentrado de entro del campo
de concentración era ver que todas
aquellas personas que tenían un sueño
toda esa que aquellas personas que
tenían un proyecto de vida que tenían
alguien a quien regresar al salir de ahí
esas personas él se dio cuenta que
lograban transformar esa pesadilla ese
trauma en fortaleza
y hoy muchos aquí estoy seguro que
conocen la historia de proyecto alcatraz
proyecto alcatraz se desarrolla o inicia
en el año 2003 en el municipio revenga
el municipio donde está la hacienda
santa teresa teníamos un municipio
sumamente peligroso la tasa a domicilio
oficial estaba en 114 homicidios por
cada 100.000 habitantes que ya es una
tasa altísima pero por noticia criminis
nosotros sabíamos que estaba muy por
encima de eso estaba en 170 homicidios
por cada 10.000 habitantes
167 y la gran pregunta era o sea
prácticamente ha habido un vacío de
orden público y la pregunta era qué pasa
cuando nos toque a nosotros qué pasa
cuando nos vienen a tocar esa puerta qué
vamos a hacer
y la verdad es que pasó de repente un
día a mí me llama el jefe de seguridad y
me dice ingeniero y me pérez
tenemos una novedad cuando jimmy pérez
dice eso ya uno empieza a pensar que
empezó el comienzo del fin del mundo
el hecho es que entran unos muchachos
pertenecientes a una banda delictiva
asaltan la empresa y después de ese
hecho nosotros empezamos a pensar qué
tenemos que hacer porque si no hay
consecuencias este es el comienzo del
fin pero a quien llama uno nos llama la
policía quién le va a venir a resolver
ese problema uno y entonces al final
terminamos llegando a una conclusión y
este es el cuento rápido terminamos
capturando a dos de esos muchachos que
eran líderes de banda y a ellos le dimos
22 opciones la primera opción era
trabajar para reponer su falta con
trabajo
la segunda era entregarlos a la policía
ellos por supuesto aceptarnos la primera
propuesta empezaron a trabajar y días
después terminamos reclutando el resto
de la banda que eran 22 personajes
y ahí empezamos un proceso un programa
de rehabilitación y reinserción ahí
empezamos poco a poco a darles
tratamiento psicológico formación para
el trabajo formación en valores
educación formal etcétera pero al cabo
de 23 meses nos dimos cuenta que sin
querer le habíamos declarar declarado la
guerra a su archirrival la peor banda
del municipio de hecho la peor banda del
eje este de aragua
y esa banda tenía además unos personajes
muy muy reconocidos y ahí nuevamente nos
encontrábamos frente a un dilema que
hacemos
esperamos que ellos vengan por nosotros
o sea que nosotros vamos por ellos
y bueno hicimos eso fuimos por ellos y
terminamos reclutando esta segunda banda
una banda hiper peligrosa con unos
rasgos psicopáticos muchos de ellos y al
final teníamos que trabajar con ellos
por separado no no se podían cruzar
porque si se llegaban a cruzar podría
haber una tragedia
de tamaño monumental adentro de la
hacienda
el hecho es que eso casi nos pasó dos o
tres veces hasta que por fin yo dije
mira esto lo tenemos que matar la
culebra como lo vamos a hacer
empezamos a ver diferentes cosas e
hicimos algo que quizás nos suene muy
inteligente y yo siempre pongo aquí no
lo practiquen en su casa pero este al
final terminamos decidiendo decirle a
las dos bandas la verdad pero no toda la
verdad
le dimos que íbamos a ver unos partidos
de rugby metimos a un primer grupo la
primera banda los metimos adentro de
este un cuartico muy pequeño por
supuesto los repetimos para asegurarnos
de que no estuvieran armados después
metimos la segunda banda también los
recreamos por supuesto se podrán
imaginar cuando estas dos bandas casi 60
criminales enemigos se encuentran en el
mismo cuarto se tenían que sentar en las
sillas hombro contra hombro
y la verdad es que lo que pasó fue
increíble yo estaba en el frente del
salón hablando y nadie me estaba
escuchando todos estaban viendo el piso
y yo hoy en día he llegado a la
conclusión que lo que estaban sintiendo
era pánico
rabia miedo
traición que yo los había traicionado
ira dolor todo eso lo están sintiendo y
mientras tanto yo estaba hablando cosas
que parecían de iluso y salió optimista
y yo decía
yo sé que ustedes aquí todos tienen la
valentía suficiente como para matarse
pero yo quiero saber si son lo
suficientemente valientes como para
perdonarse
nadie miraba para arriba y yo entonces
empiezo a meterme por ese carril y
empiezo a ponerle mucha presión
hasta que por fin llegue casi a
insultarlos y uno que está el final de
la sala que le decían el apodo de él era
para tapiche levanta la cara y me mira
con cara de rabia y yo creo que lo que
está haciendo tú sino que no nos tiene
que insultar
bueno entonces vente para acá porque si
tú eres bien valiente para matarte vente
para acá si tú eres valiente para hablar
esto con con todo lo que estamos aquí
total que se viene de darwin perdón pata
para el frente de la sala y de
ahí empiezo a golpear al otro grupo y
qué pasó el otro lado del otro lado
aquí no hay culebras o no hay agallas
por fin se termina levantando el gordo
líder de la otra banda de la primera
banda total que ellos llegan al frente
de la sala y yo le digo yo quiero saber
yo sé que usted ya se han tratado a
matar una cantidad veces de hecho los
dos tenían tiros del otro
pero yo quiero saber o sea yo no tengo
duda de que ustedes son lo
suficientemente valientes para matarse
pero yo quiero saber si son lo
suficientemente valientes para hacer una
tregua
para hacer las paces para perdonar se
dicen si no hay nada como ponerle
presión a un líder de banda frente al
resto de la banda y frente al enemigo
por supuesto dijeron que si no
demuestran lo demuestran
y entonces los dos
mirando para el piso dicen si va
yo no para eso no sólo funciona si eso
no es iba a darle otra vez tiene que
hacerlo con sentimiento si va
no es suficiente tiene que ser
convincente tiene que estar ahí total
que es 78 iteraciones hasta que por fin
yo liberado
esto funciona así se tiene que dar la
mano se tiene que mirar a los ojos y se
tienen que dar una palabra caballero ahí
es como se mata la culebra total que
estos dos personajes matones los dos se
agarran de la mano
y solo podían verse las manos no podían
mirar hacia arriba
eso es el silencio el silencio total
duró por lo menos un minuto a mí me
pareció eterno y no lograban subir la
mirada y se estaban agarrando de la mano
y de repente un momento y fue casi que
sincronizado con el otro de repente los
dos y yo hoy en día interpretó que las
emociones eran lo que no permitían que
subieran los ojos subieran la mirada y
poco a poco la razón empezó a tomar
control de sus cuerpos y de sus
emociones y empezaron a obligar a los
ojos a subir y entonces de la mano los
ojos pasaron al antebrazo al codo al
hombro al botón de la camisa al mentón y
de repente cuando las dos miradas se
cruzan sucede como un
una explosión de energía y los tipos se
miran a los ojos dicen si va
y yo muchas veces me he preguntado qué
fue eso
qué fue eso y fue un tema de
reconocimiento pero el reconocimiento
profundo de la persona de la mirada del
alma
pero esa energía
no solo se quedó ahí
[Aplausos]
resulta que esa energía se regó se fue
común como una es una onda expansiva
dentro de ese exe cuartico y de repente
todos esos enemigos que se habían estado
disparando desde hace casi 10 años donde
habían matado 30 personas entre uno y el
otro no habían una cantidad de muertos
de esos de esas dos bandas familiares
hermanos tíos una mamá
resulta que ahí se empezaron a levantar
a abrazarse ya decir cómo empezó esta
vaina cómo empezamos
bueno lo que pasó ahí esa onda expansiva
no solamente fue con esa gente se regó
en todo el municipio llegó a las
cárceles y prácticamente una semana
teníamos 6 bandas haciendo cola para
entrar el proyecto alcatraz
desde entonces bueno hemos reclutado 10
bandas de hecho ahorita estamos
reclutando la banda número 11 ya lo
puedo me dijeron que lo podía decir
todavía no tenemos
todos los pasos cubiertos pero es una
banda altamente peligrosa este que creo
que al lograrla reclutar va a tener un
impacto tremendo pero el hecho es que
hemos tenido más de 200 criminales de
alta peligrosidad que han pasado por el
proyecto más de 3000 personas
a quien le enseñamos los valores a
través del rugby nos enfocamos en cinco
valores que son el respeto la disciplina
el trabajo en equipo la humildad que es
el más importante porque la humildad es
es la herramienta para aprender de sus
errores y él no recuerdo cuál se me
olvidó pero el espíritu deportivo no
darse la mano después de entrar se
agolpen después del partido resulta que
eso además después pasamos a las
cárceles empezamos con tocorón y la pgv
y después de ahí hemos ido a diez y ocho
cárceles y hoy me enteré que abrimos
ayer la número 19 en margaritas que es
la tercera femenina cárcel
femenina que estamos atendiendo usando
el rugby como plataforma para enseñar
valores
para nosotros hay muchos logros para
nosotros el logro principal que
buscábamos era reducir la tasa homicidio
que bajó de 170 homicidios por cada
habitante 214 oficiales a 12 en los
primeros 10 años por supuesto eso
significó más de ahorita no hemos sacado
ese cálculo hacia tiempo pero son cerca
de 700 personas que dejaron de ser
asesinadas en esos primeros 10 años por
supuesto
para nosotros lo otro fue un aprendizaje
profundo que es que todo el mundo merece
una oportunidad
y cuando digo eso pienso siempre las
primeras veces que yo pisaba las
cárceles que prácticamente era un
basurero de gente
un desecho humano prácticamente disculpe
lo duro que lo esté diciendo pero ahí
descubrimos el potencial ilimitado que
tiene cada individuo y ahí justamente
vimos como ese para tapiche y el gordo
se convirtieron en darwin o pino y josé
gregorio hernández
josé gregorio hernández pero josé
gregorio arrieta así
estos personajes antes eran enemigos se
convirtieron en amigos después se
hicieron muy amigos se hicieron
compadres estos son ellos después
haciendo una presentación en nueva york
hace como dos años
y los dos convirtieron ese liderazgo que
era el liderazgo violento lo
convirtieron el liderazgo virtuoso
liderar el ejemplo de hecho los dos son
reclutadores de los mismos muchachos que
son reclutados por las bandas hacer
personas de bien
entonces
yo quisiera que imaginemos
e imaginemos por un segundo
en estos 20 años de confrontación
de polarización que ha generado heridas
profundas sufrimiento
atropellos éxodo de tantos venezolanos
imaginemos que esa confrontación esa
polarización es esa barrera que tenemos
que traspasar poniendo los ojos de todos
los venezolanos en el en el futuro
y en ese futuro
en ese futuro para ese futuro yo no
puedo ser sino optimista